David Boder: [In English] France, September the 12th, 1946, at Hénonville, about fifty (50) kilometers from Paris, a home which is maintained jointly by the Ajuda, with the educational supervision of the ORT. The interviewee is Mr. Ephraim Gutman.
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Also, Herr Gutman, wollen Sie mir sagen noch wie heißen Sie, wo sind Sie geboren und wie alt sind Sie?
Ephraim Gutman: Gutman, Ephraim, geboren neunzehn hundert siebzehn in der Ukraine. Ich hab gelebt die ganze Zeit in Litauen, Kovno, Hauptstadt Kovno.
David Boder: Ja, also Sie haben in Kovno gelebt.
Ephraim Gutman: Jawohl, ich habe gelebt in Kovno.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, Herr Gutman, ...
Ephraim Gutman: Bitte.
David Boder: ..... ....... wo sind Sie gewesen und was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn der Krieg hat angefangen. (unverständlich)
Ephraim Gutman: Ja. Am 22. Juni wenn hat ausgebrochen, da hab ich gelebt in Kovno.. Am drei, am drei und zwanzigsten (23.) Juni haben die Russen abgezogen von Litauen, von Kovno.
David Boder: Da ist der Krieg ausgebrochen zwischen Russland ....... (beide reden zur gleichen Zeit)
Ephraim Gutman: Russland und Deutschland.
David Boder: Ja, aber da war Krieg bevor.
Ephraim Gutman: Ja.
David Boder: Sie haben gelebt in Kovno – unter wem war Kovno dann?
Ephraim Gutman: Kovno war dann offiziell unter den Litauern, aber ist schon gewesen angeschlossen an den Sowjet Verband und es ist gewesen Litauische SSR und dann am zwei und zwanzigsten (22.) Juni 1941, wenn der Krieg ist ausgebrochen – wenn Deutschland rückt vor nach Russland und am nächsten Montag Morgen haben wir gesehen, wie Russland läuft weg von Litauen. Dann haben alle Juden von Kovno die Russen laufen sehen und es sind ja neunzig Prozent (90%) Juden, gesagt, sie gehen mit der Roten Armee nach Russland. Leider ist nur ein kleiner Teil gewesen, der mit den Russen zu erreichen nach Russland. Der Rest musste kehren zurück nach Kovno. Und – auf den Wegen – bei den Wegen mit den Juden, die gerade nach Kovno zurück kehren, waren schon die Litauischen Partisanen, die sind schon vorher angeheuert von der Gestapo. Und die haben gefangen die Juden und gebracht in das neunte Fort, das ist nicht weit von Kovno, und dort wurden die armen Leut erschießen. Und also das hat angefangen .... der Krieg hat angefangen am Sonntag und Mittwoch bei Nacht haben die Litauer .... am Mittwoch in der Nacht ein Programm in Slobodka, das ist ein Vorort von Kovno. Dort haben sie ermordet Mittwoch in der Nacht und Donnerstag Nacht, es war der Erste des Monats Tammuz – da haben sie ermordet ungefähr bei drei tausend (3000) Juden. Den Rabbiner von Slobodka, zum Beispiel, haben sie ermordet – er sitzt mit dem Talmud lernen. Und dann haben sie den Kopf da abgeschnitten und gezeigt durch das Fenster.
David Boder: Nun, also und wo sind Sie gewesen? Was ist Ihnen passiert?
Ephraim Gutman: Ich war auch unter die Juden,die mit den ..... die mit den Russen zusammen und sind weggelaufen. Und wir waren ungefähr dreißig Kilometer (30 km) von Kovno. Wir waren schon in Ynovo und dann wir ziehen und da haben wir schon gesehen, dass in der Stadt weiter Vilkomir – oder wie es litauisch heißt Ukmerge oder Uknage, da haben wir schon gesehen die Russen, nein ich meine die Deutschen. Die Deutschen waren dort mit den Litauern zusammen, weil es hat sich ergeben die Möglichkeit zuvor die Russen (unverständlich). Und wir haben gesehen, dass es unmöglich war nach Russland zu gehen. Und wir haben gewartet einige Tag bis es scheint zu war eine Ordnung in Kovno, und dann Sabbat, den ersten Sabbat, sind wir zurück nach Kovno. Und dort wurden wir gleich aufgehalten bei den Partisanen, den sogenannten Partisanen, was wirklich war Horde von Litauern, und sie wollten fuhren nach dem neunten Fort.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit „Euch“?
Ephraim Gutman: Euch ist mir, mit meiner Mutter und neun (9) Brüder und Schwestern.
David Boder: Neun Brüder .....?
Ephraim Gutman: (unterbricht – beide reden) Ich bin der Zehnte und leider sind geblieben nur ich von der gesamten Mischpoke. Von der Mutter und von neun (9) Brüdern und Schwestern bin ich nur alleine da und ....
David Boder: Und wo ist der Vater gewesen?
Ephraim Gutman: Der Vater ist gewesen ein‚Deiin’ in Kovno und gestorben ..... zwei Brüder hat er mit gehabt und er ist gestorben neunzehn hundert vierzig (1940) in Kovno.
David Boder: Was heißt „Deiin“?
Ephraim Gutman: Ein Deiin ist ein Rabbiner in Kovno.
David Boder: Nun?
Ephraim Gutman: Ja, und die Litauer wollten uns auch mit jagen zum Fort und zum Glück war da ein Litauer, ein Bekannter Litauer von uns, und er hat gehabt eine Armbinde mit einem Hakenkreuz, das ist, er war Partisan und da kommen die ....
David Boder: Ein Faschist – ein Partisan?
Ephraim Gutman: Ein Faschist, ja. Und er hat uns erkannt und hat gebeten seine Kameraden also sie sollen uns los lassen, weil wir doch die Kovno Rabbiner Familie. Und dann sind wir nach Kovno und die Stimmung in dem war schrecklich. Die Menschen wurden geschnappt und geführt zum Fort zu erschießen. Da will ich dazu sagen, diese alten Befestigungen von dem Zar in seiner Zeit vor dem Krieg, das ist um neunzehn hundert vierzehn (1914) gemacht wurden rund um Kovno. Das ist eine richtige Befestigung geworden und dorthin hat man geführt alle Juden zum erschießen. Und so haben wir gelebt ungefähr ein Woch; Juden im allgemeinen gingen nicht auf die Gasse, weil sowie sie auf der Gasse waren, hat man sie genommen und zum Fort erschießen. Und dann ist gekommen der Appell, dann ist gekommen General Paul, der soll nicht gehalten werden für General Paulus. Das ist der General, der gekommen ist nach Kovno und hat dort verhandelt mit dem Rabbiner von Kovno, (unverständlich) um zu schaffen ein Ghetto bei Kovno, das ist Slobodka.
David Boder: Und wer war Paulus?
Ephraim Gutman: Paulus, das ist der General, welcher (unverständlich) hatte bei Stalingrad, der deutsche General, der (unverständlich) bei Stalingrad. Und Paul ist der General, der belagert hat Kovno, der siegreiche General.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und dieser siegreiche General hat verhandelt mit dem Rabbi von Kovno das geformt wird ein jiddischer Rat von mehrere Juden, die das Vertrauen des Rabbi von Kovno hatten und die verhandeln über ein Ghetto in Kovno. Sehen Sie, er hat reagiert, dass die Juden meistens von den Litauern schlecht behandelt werden und das war so und er hat geraten wir sollen die Juden von den Litauern separieren und gehen in ein Ghetto. Und am dritten (3.) Sabbat wurde ein Befehl gegeben, dass die Juden gelbe Armbänder tragen sollen und ein Davidstern nur auf der Brust und so ....
David Boder: Was soll heißen ‚nur auf der Brust’?
Ephraim Gutman: Weil etwas später im Ghetto war der Befehl nicht nur auf der Brust, sondern auch auf dem Rücken.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und am Anfang haben wir nur getragen den Stern auf der Brust. Später kam der Befehl, dass die Juden nicht auf dem Gehsteig gehen dürfen, die Juden .... das heißt, da hat’s noch nicht ein Ghetto gegeben, die Juden dürfen gehen nur ............... nur ........
David Boder: In der Mitte .....?
Ephraim Gutman: ..........in der Mitte, mitten auf der Strasse, das heißt, genau wie ein Hund. Und viele Juden vergessen, dass sie nicht als Menschen gesehen, und sie haben vergessen und laufen auf dem Gehsteig, ah, das ist mir selber passiert da. Und dann wir kriegen geschlagen – nicht von die Deutschen, aber von die Litauer mit denen wir gelebt hundert (100) Jahre zusammen und dank ihnen, wissen wir was ein paar Schuh. Weil vorher waren sie Litauische Klumpen, das ist Holzschuh. Und (unverständlich) haben nicht verstanden zu leben und sie haben auch gar keine Bequemlichkeit gehabt.
David Boder: Und warum sagen sie „dank uns“?
Ephraim Gutman: Sie verdanken der jüdischen Entwicklung, verdanken der jüdischen Industrie, verdanken der jüdischen Kultur haben sie geworden Menschen, wie andere Menschen auch und dann auch getragen haben ein paar Schuh. In Litauen ist bekannt, auch in Russland und überall, dass der Litauer bekannt ist litauische Klumpe. Klumpe heißt a hölzerner Schuh, weil das mehr ist als er je gehabt. Also wir gehen weiter.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und jetzt also ist entstanden das jüdische Ghetto und als Zeit ist gewesen der fünfzehnte (15.) August neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941), das heißt, das ist zwei (2) Monate später wie die Deutschen sind einmarschiert. Die Deutschen waren einmarschiert am dritten (3.) Tag, wo der Krieg zwischen Russland und Deutschland hat angefangen. Das war am Sonnentag und die Deutschen sind gekommen in Kovno am Dienstag um vier (4) Uhr nachmittag. Also der Appell ist gewesen, dass bis zum fünfzehnten (15.) August alle Juden kommen rein ins Ghetto. Und zwischen der Zeit ist gewesen, wie ich schon vorher erzählt hab, die Programme von Slobodka, wo über drei tausend (3000) erschossen haben und auch Massen Arreste von Juden, die zum Fort gebracht sind zum Erschießen. Das waren einfach Unzählige, vielleicht mehr viele Tausende. (unverständlich – spricht viel zu schnell) Rabbi Wassermann, das ist, das ist ein Polnischer, von (unverständlich) Polen. Und er war verschleppt von zu Hause und er wurde erschossen am dritten Tag in dem neunte Fort. Also jetzt gehen wir weiter. Bis zum fünfzehnten (15.) August soll geschlossen werden das Ghetto, das heißt alle werden herein geladen bis dann. Und die Juden mussten selber einen Zaun bauen um das Ghetto und ungefähr bis Donnerstag dann, das ist ungefähr gewesen am dreizehnten (13.), der fünfzehnte (15.) war Sabbat und am dreizehnten (13.) waren die Litauer gestanden auf der Brücke, weil da war eine Brücke von Kovno nach Slobodka über den Vilia. Da sind gestanden die Litauer auf der Brücke und die Juden haben rüber gebracht die letzten Bündeln nach Slobodka; und da standen die Litauer, die sogenannten Partisanen, das ist die Faschistenbande, und sie haben arretiert fünfzehn hundert (1500) Juden und wieder verschleppt auf den Fort, das ist als Benefize, das ist von den Kovno Juden haben sie noch fünfzehn hundert (1500) verschleppt nach dem Fort und erschossen. Also am fünfzehnten (15.) August neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) an dem Sabbat würde der Einmarsch in das Ghetto angehalten. Keine Juden durften heraus von dem Ghetto und keine Juden durften herein ins Ghetto. Auch die Litauer durften nicht rein in das Ghetto. Und schon ....
David Boder: Was soll das heissten „die Juden durften nicht herein ins Ghetto“?
Ephraim Gutman: Also, es ist abgeschlossen, die die blieben in der Stadt – erledigt, man konnte nicht herein und nicht heraus.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Ephraim Gutman: Und am sechzehnten (16.) August, das war wieder ein Sonntag, ist gekommen der Kiminskoff, ein Litauer, der ist geworden der Vermittler zwischen die Juden und die Deutschen und er ist gewesen von der deutschen Macht bestellt. Und er ist gekommen und hat geredet mit Dr. Elkos, Dr. Elkos ist gewesen der „Alter Jude“, das ist der Haupt von dem Ältesten Rat, ein sehr anständiger Mensch, ein Doktor, bei uns war Doktor in Litauen von den Bolschewiken so bekannt, dass der Präsident Atalas (unverständlich, klingt wie Metorassan) als er krank war, nur von Dr. Elkos behandelt wurde. Und er hat geredet also, dass das Archiv in Kovno auf den Kopf gestellt wurde und zum, zum Reorganisieren, dass man das wieder in Ordnung bringen werden, will er fünf hundert dreißig (530) intelligente Juden haben zum wieder in Ordnung bringen das Archiv. Und er hat zugesagt, dass am Montag in der Früh diese Juden werden geführt zu der Arbeit, sie kriegen dort gleich Essen und bei der Nacht werden sie gebracht zurück ins Ghetto. Also zu der Zeit ist noch nicht gewesen eine richtig organisierte Arbeitsautorität, das heißt die jüdische Vertretung, die machen Ordnung in der Arbeit, das heißt wer arbeitet. Und so ist es gekommen, dass die Juden selber hatten helfen müssen, die ersten fünf hundert dreißig (530) Juden zusammen zu kriegen und man hat nicht fünf hundert dreißig (530) sondern fünf hundert vier und dreißig (534), also vier (4) (unverständlich). Und man hat sie weggeführt und dann war es sieben (7) in der Nacht und die Menschen waren nicht da und auch morgens waren sie nicht da; also die Menschen – bis zum letzten Tag, wo wir im Ghetto waren – sind geblieben fort. Natürlich haben wir verstanden, dass sie nicht mehr leben, aber ganz genau haben wir das nie gewusst. Aber als das Ghetto in vierundvierzig (44) evakuiert wurde nach Deutschland, hat Dr. Elkos, er ist gestorben im Lager, hat er uns gesagt bevor er ist gestorben, dass ihm gesagt hat Gerke (unverständlich) – er ist gewesen also der Gebietskommissar, der Referent für jüdische Angelegenheiten, ein Deutscher, vielleicht von ein und zwanzig (21) Jahr, ein Sportlehrer, der hat ihm alles gesagt. Also die Juden seien erschossen worden. Und der Dr. Elkos hat dann gefragt warum, da hat er gesagt, dass 53 Juden gearbeit haben bei die Deutschen am ersten Tag beim Zucker und dass drei und fünfzig (53), drei und fünfzig (53) Säcke Zucker seien etwas verletzt und das kostete fünf hundert dreißig (530) Juden das Leben und vier (4) noch extra. Also das ist gewesen Montag, den siebzehnten (17.) August neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941).
Ephraim Gutman: Am Dienstag war das Ghetto umringt und die Deutschen kamen ins Ghetto herein massenweise und sie sind dann gegangen rauben die Häuser. Sie sind in das Haus und haben verlangt abgeben von Gold und Silber und Brillanten und (unverständlich); und dann machen sie auf alle Schrank und alles und die besseren Sachen haben sie rausgenommen und zu genommen für sich; und die besseren Möbel haben sie genommen und gestopft bei sich. Und später waren Massen-Erschießungen im Ghetto. Das Gesetz ist gewesen, wenn ein Jud sieht einen Deutschen von weitem, muss er abnehmen die Hütl und muss ihn grüßen mit ‚Guten Morgen’, egal ob der Deutsche überhaupt hin schaut oder antwortet. Und wenn die Juden ihn nicht bemerken bevor die drei (3) oder vier (4) Meter von vorderen und abnimmt die Hütl, dann hat er ihn sofort erschossen. Das alles war nur zugegriffen für das folgende Schauspiel. Später da war ein Appell, ein offizieller Appell unterschrieben von der Gestapo, dass alle Juden müssen innerhalb von einer Woche abgeben alles Gold, Silber, Brillanten, Geld und dürfen nur hundert (100) Rubel behalten. Also sehen Sie, zu dieser Zeit ist noch gegangen ein echter Rubel; der Mark und der Rubel. Der Rubel ist gewesen .... zehn (10) Rubel ist gewesen eine (1) Mark. Und man konnte nur bei sich hundert haben. Das ist – es war verarmt im Ghetto und es sollte auch weiter besser werden und alle besseren Sachen, sogar Wäsche und solche Sachen hat man müssen abgeben und alle elektrischen Sachen und solche .... und dann hat es geheißen, wer es will nicht abgeben zu der Zeit, der wird erschossen. Und dass es die Leute auch glauben, haben sie früher gemacht die Massen-Erschießungen, damals schon haben sie die Leute erschossen, dass sie ihnen glauben, dass Leben im Ghetto nur da ist zum Erschießen. Und ....
David Boder: Wo haben sie die erschossen?
Ephraim Gutman: Ja, hier im Ghetto
David Boder: Haben Sie die gesehen?
Ephraim Gutman: Ja, ja. Hier im Ghetto haben sie die ganzen Menschen erschossen mit Maschinengewehr, zwanzig Leute. Und später, wenn das hat man erledigt, dann hat es geheißen, dass wenn vorüber geht die Woch, dann wird sein, dass die Deutschen, hm, hm, .... eine Kontrolle machen, das heißt, wenn die Woche vorüber geht, da werden gemacht „Stichproben“ in deutsch und wenn man dann findet die Sachen, die da aufgezählt sind, dann wird nicht nur die Person allein erschossen, sondern der ganze Block auch, das könnte heißen, da könnte stecken daran das Leben von Hunderten von Juden. Und so, weil kein Jud will riskieren das Leben von den Anderen, haben wir buchstäblich alles abgegeben, buchstäblich von alef bis tof. Vielleicht ein Prozent (1 %) der Juden haben versteckt die besseren Sachen. Und wir Juden haben gedenkt, wir werden dafür kriegen unser Leben, aber leider ist es gewesen unser Tod. Schon in der Woche nachdem ist gekommen Koslowski, das ist ein Deutscher und er war der Ghetto Kommandant und er hat gelebt gegenüber vom Ghetto. Und er hat gesagt man hat die Nacht geschossen auf sein Kommandantur - will er doch von Dr. Elkos als Ober-Jude, er soll ihm geben fünf hundert (500) Juden zum Erschießen.
David Boder: Was für Juden?
Ephraim Gutman: Dr. Elkos ist der Ober-Jude.
David Boder: Aber-....
Ephraim Gutman: Ober-Jude, Ober-Jude. Das ist der Älteste von die Juden, vom Kommittee.
David Boder: Was für eine Sprache ist es, Aber ...?
Ephraim Gutman: Ober-Jude, das ist im Deutschen. Ober-Jude. Und ....
David Boder: Wie wird das geschrieben – das Wort?
Ephraim Gutman: Und Dr. Elkos hat ihm geantwortet, also bei Juden gibt es nicht so eine Sache wie Herausgeben zu Erschießen. Und es war deutlich angegeben in der jüdischen Religion – und trotzdem, dass Dr. Elkos nicht ein besonders religiöser Jude war – aber er war ein nationalbewusster Jud und ein Zionist und der Doktor hat angegeben, dass in der jüdischen Religion das Herausgeben zum Erschießen darf man nicht. Und in dem Fall - die Strafe ist alle erschießen, dann werden eben alle erschießen, aber kein Jud wird ausgeliefert. Und da hat der Koslowski gesagt Dr. Elkos: ‚Wenn Du wirst mir nicht geben die fünfhundert (500), dann ich nehme mehr wie fünfhundert (500)’. Und Dr. Elkos hat ihm geantwortet: ‚Es kann kosten die fünf und vierzig tausend (45000) Leben von Juden im Ghetto, aber ich werde dir nicht geben Juden zum Erschießen“. Also das ist gewesen Donnerstag .... und dann .... das Gespräch ist gewesen am Freitag Früh, wo er gesagt hat, sie haben geschossen in der Nacht von Donnerstag bis Freitag. Und schon Freitag, eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde nach dem Gespräch, ist vorgekommen, sind viele Litauer und Deutsche, das heißt die selben Litauer, die in Dienst der Gestapo waren, reinmarschiert ins Ghetto. Und sie haben abgeschnitten ein Quartal vom Ghetto und haben all die Juden geführt auf den Platz und dort – wer hat gehabt eine Karte, das ist gewesen die Jordan Karte, an sich gehabt hat die Karte, die einen Monat vorher ausgestellt wurde (Lärm vom Tape, kurze Unterbrechung), .....
David Boder: Bitte, weiter.
Ephraim Gutman: ..... der ist geblieben am Leben. Und alle die keine Karte gehabt haben, die wurden weg geführt auf den neunten Fort, das war nicht mehr das siebente Fort, aber das neunte Fort, das war gegenüber dem Ghetto, da war ein Berg und da hat man erschossen.
David Boder: Haben Sie können sehen?
Ephraim Gutman: Das Fort hat man gesehen nur am Weg in das Ghetto rein, das Ghetto ist in einem Tal, das Fort war auf dem Berg. Und vom Ghetto hat man gesehen, wie man die Menschen geführt hat auf den Berg, nicht. Und später – ich bin gewesen in der Stadt und hab gearbeitet für die Litauer, als Zwangsarbeit, und um zirka 4 Uhr, ich habe nichts gekennt oder gewusst davon, und um zirka 4 Uhr habe ich gesehen die Litauer kommen beschickert und mit jüdische Sachen. Diese Sachen habe ich erkannt, es waren alle jüdische Sachen und in die Sachen waren gewesen lauter gelbe (unverständlich – jiddisches Wort). Und ich habe die Litauer gefragt; ‚ Wir kommt ihr zu die jüdische Kleider und Mantel?’ Und sie haben gesagt, da war im Ghetto eine Aktion, das heißt eine Aktion war gewesen und man hat alle Juden erschießen.
Ephraim Gutman: Also das ist gewesen die erste (1.) Aktion. Und danach am vierten (4) September neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig ist gewesen ..... da sind gekommen die Deutschen ..... im Ghetto ist es gewesen, also ich will bemerken, im Ghetto ist gewesen zwei (2) Ghettos, ein kleines Ghetto und ein großes Ghetto, ja. Und getrennt war das kleine Ghetto vom großen Ghetto mit einer Brück, weil die haben vorher abgeschnitten zwischen die beiden Ghettos haben die Deutschen gemacht einen Weg und die machen eine Brück für die Juden zum Rüberkommen von einem Ghetto zu anderen Ghetto. An dem Tag sind sie gekommen zu dem Ghetto und haben gestellt eine deutsche Wache an der Brück und sie haben gesagt, dass kein Jud kann herein vom großen Ghetto ins kleine Ghetto oder vom kleinen Ghetto in das Grössere und dann haben sie weggeführt das ganze kleine Ghetto. Zuerst haben sie .... sind sie zum Spital und dort haben sie angezündet das Ghetto Spital mit die Menschen und mit die Doktoren zusammen und mit die Kranken zusammen. Und mit die Kinder – da haben sie am gleichen Tag, zeitig in der Früh mit dem Kinderheim, wo ist gewesen Kinder von Russland in diesem jüdischen Kinderheim, das Heim, das nach dem Kovno Rabbi (Name unverständlich) genannt war, und das haben sie angezündet dazu noch mit alle Kinder und die Kranken im Spital. Und dann haben sie geführt die Juden von dem kleinen Ghetto auf den Platz und wieder sortiert nach die Jordan Karten. Wer hat eine Jordan Karte gehabt, der ist geblieben am Leben.
David Boder: Bitte erklären Sie noch einmal, was ist eine Jordan Karte.
Ephraim Gutman: Also ein Monat bevor der ersten Aktion ist gemeldet worden, dass alle Arbeiter, Handwerker sollen registrieren beim Kommittee, beim jüdischen Kommittee. Die jüdischen Arbeiter und Handwerker haben registriert und später eine Woche ist gekommen ein Befehl, dass alle die registriert haben, sollen kommen zum Kommittee und spezielle Karten kriegen, das ist Jordan Karten. Jordan war gewesen der Referent für jüdische Angelegenheiten beim Staatskommissar Herr Kramer. Der ist also gewesen praktisch der Chef von dem Ghetto, aber nicht der Ghetto Kommandant, der Ghetto Kommandant ....
David Boder: War das der gleiche Kramer, der ist nachher gewesen in Bergen-Belsen?
Ephraim Gutman: Nein, Kramer ist gewesen der Zivil ....., der Zivil-Kommandant, der Zivil-Kommandant.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Für Kovno – nicht der Militär-Kommandant, sondern der Zivil-Kommandant. Und in dieser Sache haben sie bekannt gegeben, dass die Juden, die registriert haben als Arbeitern sollen kommen, sollen kommen und abholen Karten. Ich hab auch registriert als Facharbeiter, als Elektriker und in dem Moment, wo man geschickt wurde zum Abholen der Karte, ist das gut oder auch nicht. Zum Beispiel haben sie mich gefragt, wieviel Leute sind in meiner Mischpoke und ich habe gesagt, ich allein, obwohl ich schon gehabt hab eine Frau und eine Mutter mit acht Kin ... Brüder und Schwestern. Und wie sie mich gefragt haben: „Hast Du denn ka Mutter?“, hab ich gesagt meine Mutter ist gestorben. Das waren Lügen, aber ich befürchtet, dass mit der Karte man kann kriegen Problem. Aber später hat sich gezeigt, dass die mit der Karte nach den zwei Aktionen am Leben geblieben sind. Also das ist Jordan Karte. Klar, ja?
David Boder: Ah hm.
Ephraim Gutman: Also an dem Tag gehen wir wieder zu der zweiten (2.) Aktion – am vierten (4.) September. Zuerst haben sie angezündet das Spital mit dem Kinderheim und danach darauf haben sie auf dem Platz die Juden sortiert. Und diesmal, die Juden, die blieben am Leben, durften nicht ins kleine Ghetto rein gehen, sondern man sie hat rüber geführt in das großer Ghetto. Und die ganze Habe vom kleinen Ghetto haben die Deutschen verteilt unter sich, aber der Platz an sich wurde eingezäunt, der ganze Platz rundherum und es war nicht erlaubt dort zu leben oder ins kleine Ghetto rein zu gehen, weder Litauer noch ein Jude durfte in das kleine Ghetto.
Ephraim Gutman: Das alles war am Anfang unverständlich, aber später war es geworden klar, es war Vorbereitung für die große Aktion. Also jetzt gehen wir zu der dritten (3.) Aktion. Wir rechnen nicht was inzwischen passiert ist, schießen und so weiter. Und so am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) – ich will noch einmal sagen neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) – das ist im gleichen Jahr (unverständlich – spricht zu schnell) wird gemeldet auf der Promenaden, auf den Gassen am sieben und zwanzigsten (27.) Oktober neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941), dass alle Juden, Männer, Frauen und Kinder und die Alten und Kranke müssen morgen am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober am Morgen um sechs Uhr in der Früh sich melden und zugleich kommen auf den großen Platz, das heißt zwischen den drei (3) größten Gebäuden, Block A, Block B, Block C - am Demokraten Platz. Und dorthin müssen sie alle kommen und diesen Befehl habe ich bisher bei mir, weil es von den Archiven vom Kovno Ghetto ist angeschrieben, dass wer nicht kommt, die deutsche Polizei wird gehen durch jedes Haus. Und wer ist zu Hause geblieben, der wird erschossen. Als Ausnahme sind nur Kranke, die können nicht aufstehen vom Bett und die können liegen bleiben, nur muss unten an der Tür angeschrieben werden, dass oben in dem und dem Zimmer liegt ein Kranker. Und in dem Befehl würde auch gemeldet, dass alles Dinge bleiben offen, die Türen, die Schränke, alles bleibt offen. Also am Morgen vom acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober um sechs (6) Uhr in der Früh kommen die ganzen Juden auf diesen Platz und eine Stunde später, das ist um sieben (7) Uhr in der Früh hat man den Platz, egal dass der Platz war mitten im Ghetto, war umringt mit deutsche Soldaten und mit Litauern und dann würde gesagt, dass sich die Leute versammeln sollten gemäß ihrem Arbeitsplatz, im Ghetto waren schon die Menschen in der Arbeit und der Älteste Rat, das ist das jüdische Kommittee sollen stehen dahinter. Und die Juden, die gearbeitet haben für Gestapo als Gestapo Gehilfen - jüdische Handwerker, Tischler, Schneider, die für die Gestapo arbeiten, die sollen dahinter. Und die Jordan Brigade dahinter und die Luftplatz dahinter - also und so weiter und so weiter und jeder soll mit ihm haben die ganze Familie.
David Boder: Was heißt der Flugplatz?
Ephraim Gutman: Der Flugplatz wird in Kovno also gebaut ein riesiger Aerodrom am Flugplatz und dorthin wurden gefahren vier (4) bis sechs (6) Tausend sieben (7) Tage zur Arbeit.
David Boder: Ah. Und wer hat stehen müssen zur Seite?
Ephraim Gutman: Die, die haben gearbeitet haben müssen sich versammeln am großen Platz, die Flugplatz Arbeiter. Gemeint hat man, dass die Leute, die Flugplatz Arbeiter wichtiger sind und werden abschneiden besser, weil Arbeiter am Flugplatz muss man haben. Aber wie wir gesehen haben – also wir gehen weiter – eine halbe Stunde später um halb acht kommen die höheren deutschen Beamten, Jordan – wir machen mal schnell dieses Kreuz, Kramer, Koslowski und noch solche bösen Menschen. Und sie kommen in das Ghetto mit den kleinen Maschinen und haben gemacht, aufgestellt die Juden als wären sie, also, hm, ............
David Boder: Mit was für Maschinen?
Ephraim Gutman: Mit kleine Maschinen, nicht mit Gewehrmaschine.
David Boder: Automobil.
Ephraim Gutman: Ah hm. Und die Juden stehen herum und rundherum und da war ein gewisser Platz frei , das ist die Ältesten sind durch marschiert und gemacht (unverständlich) nicht erlaubt ....
David Boder: Die Ältesten?
Ephraim Gutman: Der Ältesten Rat, das ist jüdische Kommittee sollte durch marschieren.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und gemacht haben sie es so, dass sie durch marschieren, da haben sie die deutschen Posten so aufgestellt, dass sie ein kleines Türl gemacht, ein „Menschentürl“ um durch zu gehen. Und dort bei der Tür hat gestanden Jordan und die ganze Bande und die Ältesten Kommittee oder wie man gesagt hat der „Ältestenrat“ und die sind durch gegangen ohne Kontrolle, dass heißt, alle sind durch gegangen. Und nun wollte ich bemerken, die Welt weiß, dass links ist ärger wie rechts. Alle bei den früheren Aktionen, die Menschen, die was geführt wurden zum erschießen .... wurden nach links geschickt. Aber dieses Mal, um die Juden zu verwirren oder die Meisten, haben sie gesagt zum Ältestenrat „nach links“ und man hat angenommen man führt den Ältestenrat zum Erschießen. Später hat man dann die jüdische Polizei mit ihren Familien und die Gestapo Brigade ohne Kontrolle und die Jordan Brigade ohne Kontrolle und dann hat man plötzlich ausgerufen: „ Und jetzt geht der Flugplatz.“ Der Flugplatz wurde schon angefangen mit Sortieren. Er ist dort gestanden mit der übrigen Bande, einen halben Tag sind sie dort gestanden. Und Jordan guckt jedem ins Gesicht. Und wer ist gewesen jünger, der ist gegangen links, das ist zum Leben. Und wer älter war ist getrieben worden über den Platz – rechts. Zuerst hat man nicht gewusst, was das bedeutet rechts und links. Jordan konnte es nicht (unverständlich), auf der rechten Seite waren hunderte oder sogar Tausende von Juden und er gab den Befehl den deutschen Posten sie abzuführen. Man hat herausgefunden, nachdem man sie weggeführt in das ehemalige kleine Ghetto, das habe ich vorher bemerkt, dass es geblieben frei. Und dort haben sie gehalten die Menschen und so ist es gegangen den ganzen Tag ohne Aufhören. Wer war jünger, wer war besser gekleidet, ohne Kinder viel oder kein Alter, der ist gegangen links. Und der, wer war schlecht angezogen, ohne Kinder und so weiter, der ist gegangen rechts. Und bis in der Nacht, wo er gemerkt hat, dass er nicht kann zu überklauben die vier und vierzig tausend (44000) Juden und so schickt er ganze Partien von hundert Mann rechts, hundert links. Also da kann passieren und ist auch passiert, dass die Jüngeren gegangen sind zum Erschießen, weil Ältere zum Leben gekommen sind, weil es war ihm unmöglich zu sortieren, weil es war finster. Also die ....
David Boder: Wer war das?
Ephraim Gutman: Der Jordan, auch der Jordan.
David Boder: Jordan.
Ephraim Gutman: Später ....
David Boder: Wer war der Jordan?
Ephraim Gutman: Jordan ist gewesen SS Obersturmführer. Das ist ein (unverständlich), ein Brauner. Er selber ist ein (unverständlich), ungefähr ein und zwanzig (21), ein Sportlehrer und es scheint so ein (unverstaendich) für Menschen und das wollen die gehabt haben.
David Boder: We war er – ein Litauer?
Ephraim Gutman: Ein Deutscher.
David Boder: Was ist ihm nachher passiert?
Ephraim Gutman: Dieser Jordan ist nachher .... es war er hat jüdisches Eigentum sich angeeignet, wie der Befehl – über den ich vorher geredet habe – ist gekommen, dass jüdisches Gold und Brillanten abgeliefert werden muss, und da hat er sich die besseren Sachen, die besseren Brillanten behalten. Die übrigen Deutschen haben nicht können ihm das vergönnen und sie haben ihn angezeigt und als Bestrafung ist er gekommen an die Front. Und später wir lesen die Zeitung, in der Deutschen Zeitung, das war für uns nicht frei zu lesen, das heißt ein Jude war nicht erlaubt zu gehen in die Stadt für die Zeitung, aber wir haben sie trotzdem bekommen, und wir haben dann gelesen in der Morgenzeitung, dass der Obersturmbandführer geworden ist - im Rank noch höher - ist gefallen für den Führer und für sein Vaterland – ich mach schnell dieses Kreuz. Also gehen wir jetzt weiter. Die Juden, die Juden, wo man geführt hat rechts waren in dem kleinen Ghetto. Die Juden, die man links hin und ich war unter ihnen glücklicherweise, wurden zurück zum Ghetto gebracht und gesagt, sie sollen gehen in die Häuser. Es versteht sich, dass das Weinen und Geschrei im Ghetto war gross, Menschen sind in ihre Häuser gegangen und haben nicht gefunden den Vater, sie konnten nicht finden ihre Kinder, weil beim Sonnenuntergang, wie ich schon vorher erwähnt habe, hat man sie einfach geschickt rechts und nach links. Und im kleinen Ghetto hat man überhaupt noch nicht gewusst was passiert mit jene zwölf tausend (12000) Juden, zwölf tausend, nicht zu vergleichen mit andere Ziffern, zwölf tausend Juden und man hat nichts gewusst. Doch am Morgen ....
David Boder: Von wo wissen Sie die Nummer?
Ephraim Gutman: Am nächsten Morgen da mussten man Appell nehmen und da waren .... und da hat man gesehen, dass zwölf tausend Juden nicht waren in dem Ghetto. Und die Menschen haben sie gehalten im kleinen Ghetto, leider die Juden dort in dem kleinen Ghetto konnten sich nicht vorstellen, dass morgen man sie wird erschießen. Sie haben sich (unverständlich) über Wohnungen dorten, über Wohnungen mit Holz, über Wohnungen mit Sachen, die die Deutschen noch nicht genommen haben. Und am Morgen um sieben (7) Uhr in der Früh hat man sie aufgetrieben vom Plänkl da und gesagt zu gehen zu viert in einer Reih und dann hat man sie wieder geführt zum Fort. Und wir standen im Ghetto und haben gesehen wieder wie eine Menschenschlange stundenlang hinauf zum Fort geht und dann haben wir gehört nach einer kurzen Weil .... haben wir gehört das deutsche MG Feuer, das ist, hm, ........
David Boder: Maschinengewehr.
Ephraim Gutman: Maschinengewehr (unverständlich)
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und dann war die Sache erledigt. Am Morgen hat Dr. Elkos gefragt Jordan, was geschehen ist mit den zwölf tausend (12000) Juden und er hat gesagt: “Reden Sie net darüber. Diese Juden sind schon nicht mehr am Leben. Aber mehr wird in dem Ghetto nicht vorkommen, das ist die letzte von den Aktionen. Jetzt bleibt ihr alle am Leben.“
David Boder: Wer hat sie begraben, die zwölf tausend (12000)?
Ephraim Gutman: Da waren vorbereitete Gräber auch. Die russischen Gefangenen machen zuerst die Gräber, und dort werden aufgereiht die Menschen, unbekleidet – nackert oder in der Unterwäsch ..... und rein werfen in diese riesigen Graben. Sie waren aufgereiht bei die Graben und erschießen mit dem MG .... und dann fallen zwölf, fallen übereinander and danach darauf schütten Kalk, weil man musste Platz lassen für noch. Und so haben sie diesen Kalk darauf, um zu verhüten eine Epidemie und die Graben mit Kalk drüber für die die später begraben werden.
David Boder: Sie wurden nicht zugeschüttet die Gruben?
Ephraim Gutman: Nein, nur Kalk. Also, das ist gewesen am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) und das war gewesen richtig, wirklich die letzte Aktion im Ghetto oder besser gesagt eine der Letzten. Kleine Aktionen passieren immer noch im Ghetto, aber keine Grösseren. Und eine von den grösseren Aktionen war an dem Tag, wo gefallen ist Stalingrad – wo Deutschland verloren hat Stalingrad ...
David Boder: Nun?
Ephraim Gutman: ... da mussten sie doch etwas tun um ihren (unverständlich), da mussten sie stillen ihre Blut. Und da war dort die Litauische Polizei in Kovno – alle Juden, die da zur Arbeit waren, wenn sie heraus gehen von dem Arbeitsplatz da, soll man sie sofort arretieren und bringen zur Gestapo. Und bei Nacht ist gekommen Gestapo und hat, .... also bei Nacht ist gekommen die Gestapo in das Ghetto und hat die Familien von die Menschen weggeführt am Morgen, weggeführt auf den Fort, wieder zum neunten (9.) Fort und erschossen.
David Boder: Man hat zusammengenommen die ....
Ephraim Gutman: Die Mischpoke, die Mischpoke von denen, die arretiert wurden am Abend in Kovno.
David Boder: Und warum hat man die genommen wegen der Arbeit?
Ephraim Gutman: Nur weil sie weggetreten sind von ihrem Arbeitsplatz. Zum Beispiel: da war ein gewisser Mechaniker in Kovno, der Name war Sadowski. Er ist gegangen aus der Reihe und bettelt um ein Stück Brot ....
David Boder: Ein Jude?
Ephraim Gutman: Ein Jude. Der wollte ein Stück Brot da kriegen von einem Christen, von einer Litauer Frau. Es ist selbstverständlich, dass er nichts gekriegt von ihr, aber der Posten hat es bemerkt und hat ihn arretiert und in der Nacht sind sie gekommen und haben genommen die Frau und Tochter und haben sie am nächsten Morgen in der Früh erschossen.
David Boder: Sie sagen erschossen?
Ephraim Gutman: Wieder im neunten Fort. Später in neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig bevor (unverständlich) ist gekommen eines guten Morgens Einer von Deutschland und hat gesagt, dass von heut an weiter wird das Ghetto jetzt Konz-Lager, das Konzentrationslager Kaunas genannt und dass er der Ghetto Kommandant, der Lager Kommandant ist. Er hat geheißen Gerke, Gerke. Er war ein Obersturmbandführer – das war das Herz von der deutschen Partei. Er hat sich gezeigt von Anfang an als intelligenter Mensch. Er hat sich erkundigt über die Ernährung im Ghetto und Dr. Elkos hat ihm erklärt, dass es war fünfzig Gramm Brot und er hat gesagt „Ja, das geht doch nicht, man muss mehr kriegen – Butter und so weiter. Wichtig! Und wir haben bekommen Butter, aber leider hat es gekostet ....
David Boder: Wann war das?
Ephraim Gutman: Das war in neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943) beim (unverständlich) Fest.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und ....
David Boder: Sie meinen Butter ist Margarine?
Ephraim Gutman: Butter.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit Butter?....
Ephraim Gutman: Richtige Butter, richtige Butter!
David Boder: Wo kann man die kaufen?
Ephraim Gutman: Von den Deutschen ... oh, für sich selber haben sie gehabt, was sie gebraucht haben, haben sie von den Juden genommen. Marmelade haben sie uns gegeben. Und in dem Ghetto war so ein Spruch: „Heute kriegen wir schon eine Butter, morgen kommt eine Aktion.“ Und so am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober – wieder Oktober – am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober neunzehn hundert drei und vierzig (1943) haben sie umringelt das Ghetto von innen und sie haben drei und ein halb tausend (3500) Juden nach Estland und dorthin weg geführt.
David Boder: Nach Estland, nach Reval?
Ephraim Gutman: Nein, nach verschiedene Arbeitsplätze. Die erste .....
David Boder: Und Estland hat man genannt Russland dann?
Ephraim Gutman: Estland war gewesen ein Gebiet von Russland.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Das okkupierte Russland.
Ephraim Gutman: Zuerst hat er gesagt bevor gekommen ist der acht und zwanzigste (28.) Oktober, sie brauchen zwei tausend (2000) Juden zwanzig (20) Kilometer von Kovno für Arbeit. Dann ist heraus gekommen, das waren doch Lügen und er hat sie weg geschickt nach Estland. Die Frauen, alle von ihnen, sind geblieben im Aerodrom und sind hier von die Kinder .... die Kinder sind genommen worden von die Eltern und kleinere Kinder sind erschossen wurden alleine in Kovno. Und die Frauen mit die Männer – ohne die kleinen Kinder, die hat man gefahren nach Estland und es versteht sich, dass Wenige am Leben sind geblieben. Auch meine zwei (2) Brüder wurden verschleppt nach Estland und dorten Einer wurde erschossen und der Zweite ist später nach Deutschland. Und dort ist er auch umgekommen in Deutschland, in Auschwitz, wenn sie machen Aufstand in Auschwitz. Dieser Aufstand soll passieren in .... er war zugeteilt zu verbrennen die Toten in Auschwitz – und er mit noch fünf und dreißig (35) Juden haben beschlossen also Rache zu (unverständlich – spricht zu schnell) bevor sie selbst verbrennen. Es war ihnen klar, dass sie werden sie selbst verbrennen. So jeder deutsche Offizier, was da rein gekommen ist in ... hm, dort die Kammer .....hm, in den ... wie heißt es denn ....
David Boder: Die Gaskammer.
Ephraim Gutman: Nein, wo man verbrennt, im Krematorium. So wenn die Deutschen herein gekommen sind, stießen sie ihn von hinten und gehängt, und dann geworfen in den Ofen.
David Boder: Haben sie die nicht gesucht?
Ephraim Gutman: Und so sind viele Deutsche verschwunden bis es ist aufgefallen und der Verdacht war, dass sie alle sind weg in der Vorbereitung für die „Kammer“. Und so haben sie gewusst und sie sind alle in die Kammer geschmissen worden. Das habe ich gehört von einem Schwager, der mir es erzählt. Er hat es gehört von einem Kameraden, der geflüchtet ist. (unverstaendich)
David Boder: Von dem Krematorium?
Ephraim Gutman: Ja, vom Krematorium, ja und dass mein Bruder ist gewesen der Organisator von diesem Aggressionsakt gegen die Deutschen. Also jetzt gehen wir weiter. Das Ghetto, also nicht das Ghetto, sondern das Konz-Lager, die Aktionen gingen weiter, aber seit der Aktion gegen drei ein halb Tausend (3500) sind keine Massenaktionen mehr vorgekommen. Nur am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) .... am sieben und zwanzigsten (27.) und acht und zwanzigsten (28.) März neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944), neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944) ist vorgekommen die Kinder Aktion und die Alters Aktion, ein Aktion für Kinder und alte Menschen. Ich muss anmerken, dass der Gerke sehr raffiniert war. Er hat da scheinbar Praxis von andere Ghettos und anderen Lagern gehabt, weil alle Aktionen gegen die Leute im Ghetto haben einen Vorahnung gehabt, dass etwas sollte vorkommen.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes, this concludes Spool 124 of Mr. Ephraim Gutman and we are going over, we are going over to Spool 125. We are taking now about the so-called Aktion gegen Alte und Kinder. Paris, September the 12th, 1946, in Hénonville.
David Boder: This spool, which is called 125 should really be called 125A because there is another section of an interviewee. January 29, 1950. Boder.
David Boder: This is Spool 125, Mr. Ephraim Gutman reporting, a continuation of Spool 124. France, Hénonville, fifty Kilometers (50 km) from Paris at a home maintained by for displaced Jews, maintained by the Agudah in combination with the ORT.
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Also Sie haben gesagt, man hat angefangen eine Aktion gegen alte Menschen und Kinder.
Ephraim Gutman: Ja.
David Boder: Wenn und was ist gewesen und was war das?
Ephraim Gutman: Das ist gewesen am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober, am acht und zwanzigsten (28.) und sieben und zwanzigsten (27.) März neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944). Also ich will noch einmal bemerken, dass vor einer Aktion, dass etwas gespielt hat, also die Luft war nicht in Ordnung – es war etwas was wir im Ghetto gespürt haben, das etwas passiert gegen das Ghetto. Und am sechs und zwanzigsten (26.) abends ist gekommen Gerke, der Lager Kommandant ....
David Boder: Wie schreibt man seinen Namen?
Ephraim Gutman: Gerke.
David Boder: G – e –c – k –e (buchstabiert)?
Ephraim Gutman: Das weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Also da ist gekommen Gerke, Gerke ging zur Polizei, zum Chef der jüdischen Polizei und hat gesagt, dass morgen Früh, das heißt am sieben und zwanzigsten (27.) März neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) die jüdische Polizei soll versammeln alle (unverständlich) vor der deutschen Kommandantur für das Ghetto ... in dem früheren Ghetto, das ist in dem jetzigen Lager, das ist ....
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir ein paar Wörter über die jüdische Polizei.
Ephraim Gutman: Das ist ... dort diese Polizei werden wir sprechen während der Kinderaktion und da werden Sie sehen wie die sind.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: .... und sie sollen alle kommen, damit sie hören was sie vorhaben und eine Rede hören. Und sie sind gekommen, ganz sauber angezogen ...
David Boder: Die jüdische Polizei?
Ephraim Gutman: Ja, am morgen in der Früh ist gekommen die Polizei, es war acht (8) und sowie sie sind gekommen zur deutschen Kommandantur, sind vom Korridor herausgegangen von der deutsche Kommandantur – sind heraus gegangen die Belarussen, das sind die Ukrainer, in Russland hat man sie Vlasovzi genennt, dass heißt die Ukrainer, die da gekämpft haben für Deutschland. Und die sind da raus mit den Flinten in der Hand und haben gesagt die jüdische Polizei muss sich auf den Boden legen mit dem Gesicht auf der Erd. Und dann sind gekommen Lastautos mit Maschinengewehren und dann haben sie eingepackt und gebracht zum neunten (9.) Fort. Also das war alles nur ein Vorspiel für das weitere Spiel. In dem Moment ....
David Boder: Haben Sie umgebracht die Polizei?
Ephraim Gutman: Leider nein, sind geblieben am Leben viele von der Polizei, ich sag das noch einmal, leider sind am Leben geblieben von der Polizei a bisserl. Später .....
David Boder: Was heißt a bisserl? Was haben sie getan mit den Anderen?
Ephraim Gutman: Darüber werd ich Ihnen bald erzählen von die dann. Also später nach einer Weile, wenn sie alle heraus geführt vom Ghetto, kommt eine kleine Maschine ins Ghetto, ein Taxi mit (unverständlich)
David Boder: Einem was?
Ephraim Gutman: Mit einem Megafon, Lautsprecher.
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und darin ist gesessen ein Mann, ob es war ein Deutscher oder ein Jud, das können wir nicht wissen. Und die kleine Maschine ist dann durch das ganze Ghetto gefahren und hat gerufen: „Achtung, Achtung! Alle Juden sollen gehen in die Häuser, wenn nicht werden sie erschossen.“ Das heißt, dass alle Juden ihre Arbeitsplätze liegen lassen müssen und im Ghetto waren viel Arbeitsplätze. Das Ghetto selber war die Größe einer Stadt und es gab viele Geschäfte im Ghetto selber, und in die großen Laden haben viele tausend Juden gearbeitet. Auf jeden Fall gab es auch viel kleine Laden für die Juden im Ghetto – oder für die Juden in dem – wie sagen sie später – Lager. Auf jeden Fall hat jeder müssen laufen und alles muss in dem Moment zu einem Stop gebracht werden und alle gehen in ihre Häuser. Die Leute haben verstanden, dass etwas jetzt kommt vor. Die Menschen haben schon Versteckplätze hergerichtet oder im Ghetto hat man sie genannt „Malines“ ....
David Boder: Was „Malines“?
Ephraim Gutman: Malines.
David Boder: Nicht Bunker?
Ephraim Gutman: Bunker ist in deutsch. Und „Malines“ stammt von dem Wort „malon“, in hebräisch (unverständlich). Im Ghetto heißt es „Malines“, das stammt von den Galonen, es scheint, weil die Galonen stammen ab von die Malinen, von dem Wort Galgen und das sind Malinen, das ist der Galgen.
David Boder: Jüdische Galonen?
Ephraim Gutman: Ja und da sind wir geblieben im Ghetto in den Malines, wer gehabt hat im Ghetto ist geflüchtet in die Malines. (unverständlich) und die Maschinen sind durchs ganze Ghetto und der Rest wurde in großen Lastwagen gebracht – das waren Belarussen, das heißt wieder die Vlasovzi und die Deutschen und Litauer mit ihren Flinten und damit sind sie gegangen von Tür zu Tür. Und wo sie gesehen haben ein kleines Kind, da haben sie genommen das Kind oder gezwungen die Mutter, dass sie das Kind raus führt und da ist ein Lastwagen an der Ecke gestanden und hat man es hinein gehaut. Und so haben die gearbeitet den ganzen Tag. Die jüdische Polizei ist noch gewesen in dem Moment auf den neunten (9.) Fort und sie waren noch nicht ganz erschossen. Also diese Aktion hat man hinaus gezögert bis sieben (7) Uhr bei der Nacht. Dann .....
David Boder: Wie viel Menschen waren gewesen bei der jüdischen Polizei?
Ephraim Gutman: Die jüdische Polizei hat gehabt mehr als drei hundert (300).
David Boder: Oh! Haben sie getragen eine Uniform?
Ephraim Gutman: Sie haben ... sie haben getragen nur ein Hütl, so ein Hütl mit Magen David und J.G.P. – das heißt „jüdische Ghetto Polizei“ oder später ist gewesen Lager-Polizei und auf dem Arm, auf der rech .... auf der linken Hand haben sie getragen ein Band mit einem blauen Magen David und darin war gestanden: J.G.P. – jüdische Ghetto Polizei mit einer Nummer. Jede Ghetto Polizei hat eine Nummer, erstens die Werknummer und zweitens die Nummer in welchem Quartal er hat Dienst gehabt. Und ....
David Boder: Haben sie gehabt einen Revolver?
Ephraim Gutman: Nein, keine Gewehre haben sie gehabt.
David Boder: Was haben sie gehabt?
Ephraim Gutman: Nur kalte Gewehr, das ist nur a Stöckel oder eine Nagyka und die Aktion war fertig um sieben (7) Uhr in der Nacht und die Menschen sind dann gekommen – und ich will bemerken, an dem Tag in dem Ghetto sie spielen, dass sie nichts bemerken ..... (unverständlich) und die Menschen, die gehen jeden Tag zu der Arbeit’ hat man auch geschickt zu der Arbeit, und die Bataillons. Und die Menschen werden gefahren zu der Arbeit, die jeden Tag zur Arbeit fahren. Und wenn die Menschen sind gekommen von der Arbeit zurück da hat (unverständlich) ..... und da hat man die Gesichter gesehen; Menschen sind gekommen von der Arbeit und da haben sie nicht gefunden nicht den Vater, nicht die Mutter und nicht ihre Kinder und .....
David Boder: Sie haben doch gesagt, am Morgen hat man nur gesucht nach die Kinder.
Ephraim Gutman: Oh ja, Vater und Mutter sind auch gewesen dasselbe. Die Alten und die Kleinen sind am ersten Tag gegangen zusammen. Die Aktion war für Alte und kleine Kinder, aber sie haben sich konzentriert auf kleine Kinder. Und das Geschrei was furchtbar und sie haben gemeint, das war das Ende der Aktion, weil es üblich, dass die Aktionen in dem Ghetto nur gedauert haben einen Tag. Leider hat man gesehen, dass die spezielle Wache ......ich will bemerken, dass man am Tag der Aktion das Ghetto speziell bewachte ....
David Boder: Aha.
Ephraim Gutman: ... dass man das Ghetto speziell bewachte, weil in der (unverständlich – spricht zu schnell) und wenn die Aktion vorüber war um sieben (7) Uhr am Abend, die Polizei ist noch immer da gestanden rund um den Zaun. Und es hat sich verstanden, dass was passieren würde wieder. Vor gestellt hat man sich, also sie machen eine allgemeine Aktion morgen, das heißt eine Grössere. Aber am nächsten Morgen zeitig früh um fünf (5) Uhr hat sich wiederholt das Spiel, nur etwas Besonderes, in einer anderen Form. Zuerst sind sie gegangen suchen ..... am zweiten Tag haben sie gesucht nach Versteckplätzen in Hütten, und wo sie selbst entdeckt haben Malines, aber jetzt haben sie gebracht die jüdische Polizei. Also der ‚Kittel’, das ist gewesen der Chef der Gestapo für jüdische Angelegenheiten, er ist gewesen der Liquidator vom Vilna Ghetto und seine Arbeit was schon im Jahre drei und vierzig (43) beendet, das heißt das Vilna Ghetto war schon liquidiert im Jahre drei und vierzig (43) auf diese Art und Weise ....
David Boder: Wie war es liquidiert?
Ephraim Gutman: Also alle wurden geführt nach Estland. Dort hat man sie liquidiert – die meisten hat man erschossen in (unverständlich klingt wie Bernal), das ist nicht weit weg von Vilna. Ja, ich komm bald. (Murmeln)
David Boder: Sie haben gesprochen über die Aktien am nächsten Tag.
Ephraim Gutman: Ja und die jüdische Polizei war im neunten (9.) Fort und dann ist gekommen ‚Kittel’, das ist der der liquidiert hat das Vilna Ghetto, ist gekommen nach dem neunten (9.) Fort, wo die jüdische Polizei gewesen ist ver , ver , hm, arretiert und hat gemeldet: da sie eh alle erschossen werden, will er ihnen ein Chance geben zum leben und sie sollen nur verweisen auf die Malines in dem Ghetto, das sind, wo die Juden sind verhalten, kleine Kinder und alte Menschen. Viele dieser leider haben nicht können der Versuchung widerstehen zu bleiben am Leben und sie sind rein in die Maschinen mit Kittel und sind dann gekommen ins Ghetto und haben gezeigt wo sind die Malinen.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gemeint mit Vielen? Sie haben gesagt es wären gewesen Dreihundert (300).
Ephraim Gutman: Dreihundert (300) jüdische Polizei und unter denen sind gewesen sechzig (60) von denen man weiß, dass sie sind gekommen mit der Maschine ins Ghetto und haben gezeigt, wo diese sein können. Ich muss bemerken, dass Kunst ist nicht nur zu finden die Maline und diesem oder diesem Gebäude, aber man musste verweisen, wie man rein geht in die Maline. Und da muss man wissen, wie man rein kam und sie haben von da die Kinder und Alten genommen und geführt zum Fort zum Erschießen. Die Polizei .....
David Boder: Wie hat das die jüdische Polizei gewusst?
Ephraim Gutman: Die jüdische Polizei ..... die, die machen diese Malinen haben die jüdischen Polizei nicht (unverständlich), weil die waren ihr Freund. Es wurde angenommen, es war ein Freund, es hat sich aber gezeigt, sie waren unser Feind. In dem Moment wo sie Angst gehabt haben, um ihr Leben, haben sie es besser gefunden zu opfern die Juden Leben, so dass sie allein leben. Und da hat man heraus gefunden alle Malinen, buchstäblich alle Malinen im Ghetto und alle versteckt gehaltenen Kinder wurden verschleppt. Und vierzig Prozent (40%) aller Kinder sind jedoch im Ghetto versteckt geblieben, das ist, die Kinder, die in Malinen waren, sind doch nicht am Leben geblieben. Aber die Kinder, die in anderen Verhalten, die nicht so sicher waren, wie unter dem Bett oder unter einer Tuchent versteckt, sind doch geblieben am Leben. Und am Abend war die Aktion beendigt und am zweiten (2.)Tag das Resultat ist noch ärger gewesen als der Erste, das heißt für die Deutschen war es ein Besserer, für uns war es ein noch Ärgerer. Das ist es waren noch mehr Opfer am zweiten Tag, als am ersten Tag. Ich möchte noch sagen, wenn sie die Kinder gefunden haben, viele Mamas wollen mit ihren ... mit ihren Kindern zusammen, weil man gesagt hat, die Kinder erschießt man, doch die Deutschen haben aber das nicht so gesehen und haben keine jüdischen Mamas geopfert. Sie haben zum Beispiel gesagt zu meiner Schwester, als sie nehmen ihr Kind – sie hat sie gebeten, denn sie wollte mit dem Kind gehen zusammen, aber der Deutsche hat gesagt: „Ja, du musst noch arbeiten, du kannst noch jetzt leben, deine Reihe kommt auch.“ Das ist: „Deine Reihe kommt auch, (unverständlich) darfst Du noch haben.“
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: Und am Tag ist gewesen, in der Nacht – wieder um sieben (7) Uhr in der Nacht ist gewesen vorbei die Aktion für die Kinder. Dazu möchte ich bemerken, dass die Aktion gegen die Kinder hat den stärksten Eindruck gemacht in dem Ghetto, noch mehr als die große Aktion vom acht und zwanzigsten (28.) Oktober neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig (1941) gegen zwölf tausend (12000) Juden.
David Boder: Den Stärksten was?
Ephraim Gutman: Den stärksten Eindruck, den schrecklichsten Eindruck .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ephraim Gutman: .... weil das war die Kinder .... zu sehen, wie sie nehmen die Kinder und die alten Leut, das ist eine Zubereitung zur Vernichtung des ganzen Ghettos, oder wie es später geheißen hat Lager. Also das war beendigt, die Aktion gegen die Kinder war beendigt. Die Kinder, das heißt in der ersten Zeit waren die verhaltenen Kinder waren gewesen (unverständlich), sie konnten nicht raus auf die Gasse, aber wieder nach ein paar Wochen haben die Kinder, die man versteckt gehabt hat, sich schon wieder auf der Strasse gezeigt. Und was ist passiert mit der Polizei? Die Polizei, die den Deutschen zu den Malines hingebracht hat, die hat die Polizei wieder in das Ghetto gelassen. Sie haben erschossen alle von der höheren Polizei. Also es war wie bei normaler Polizei, wie das ist in allen Ländern, das hat es gegeben höhere Beamte und niedere Beamte, wie die Litauer gesagt haben (unverständlich – litauische Worte), das ist ein Höherer und ein Niedrigerer. Und sie haben alle Höheren erschossen, weil während der Zeit auf dem Fort alle Geheimnisse von dem Ghetto wurden verraten. Das heißt, die jüdische Polizei, dass heißt die Niedrigeren haben gesagt, dass in dem Ghetto ..... das von dem Ghetto wir zu den Partisanen gehen, das ist zusammen mit den roten Partisanen gehen und dass es im Ghetto gibt Gewehr und so weiter und weiter. Und so haben verantwortlich gemacht die Höheren der jüdischen Polizei, weil ...
David Boder: Meinen Sie höher und niedriger in Charakter oder im, im Rang?
Ephraim Gutman: Nein, wir meinen im Rang. Wenn wir reden höher, meinen wir den Rang. Von etwas höheren Polizisten bis zum Chef der Polizei werden alle erschossen. Da war ein Moshe Levin, er war der Chef der jüdischen Polizei in dem Lager, damals haben sie es schon genannt Lager. In dem Ghetto war er nicht besonders stark in Nettigkeiten oder in der Rede mit die Juden, aber ich muss zugeben, als in dem Moment, wo er mit den Deutschen im Fort war, war er die, er hat gepredigt der jüdischen Polizei, dass sie nicht verraten sollen vom Ghetto den Deutschen, weil man sie so wie so wird erschießen und man darf nicht verflecken den jüdischen Namen.
David Boder: A remark of the translator David P. Boder. Chicago, January the 29th, 1950. This is a duplicate spool prepared under the Public Health Grant... and the will be listed or cataloged as Spool 125A, because we discovered that on the same spool there is a start of another interview, which we will then call Spool 125B. The interview was discontinued abruptly, and it’s hard to tell for what reason — at times the interviewee, who by this time has been talking for about an hour or so, hm, was called away on some special duty in the A-j-u-d-a. This is the end of Spool 125A, the end of Spool 125A, the end of Spool 125A. Taken in Hénonville, France, September the 12th, 1946.